our next topic
is angle so we'll be able to define the
angle
between two vectors it's gonna it's
gonna be the same as the angle
between vectors that are have dimension
two
and three uh but we're going to be able
to talk about things like the angle
between two vectors of dimension
a thousand uh which is a
very interesting concept
so we're going to start with something
called the koshi schwartz inequality and
it's named for two mathematicians
uh well koshi and schwartz um so
and it says this it says if i have any
two n vectors a and b
then uh the inner product the absolute
value of the inner product
is less than or equal to the product of
the norms that's that's here
and so if you if you write it out in
terms of coefficients it says this it
says that
the absolute value of the sum of the
corresponding products that's that's the
that's the inner product
is less than that's the norm of a and
that's times the norm of b
um and if you have once you have the
triangle and you know
once you have the kosher schwartz
inequality you can establish the
triangle inequality and
let's see how that works they're related
um a plus b
norm squared is equal to and i'm simply
going to multiply
everything out because that's a plus b
inner product with
a plus b and that's equal to the inner
product of
a with itself plus the inner product of
a with b plus the other way around
and then plus that okay this
is norm a squared that's right here
this term is right there and then these
two are both a number and they're the
same number it's the inner product of a
and b or b and a it's the same number
and so that goes in this middle one
so i've derived that first line now i'm
going to use the koshi schwarz
inequality in the middle thing
2 inner product of a and b and i'm going
to say that that is less than or equal
to 2 times the norm of a times b
and i get this but that's exactly equal
to that and now i take the square root
of this
and i find that uh
a plus b the norm of that is less than
or equal to
the norm of a plus the norm of b and
that's the triangle inequality
so once we know the koshi schwartz
inequality
will we can actually show the triangle
inequality from that
so let's derive takoshi schwartz
inequality um
this is also something where you know
it's probably best for you to derive
this yourself and
on your own terms and things like that
but we'll just do it here because it's
not
that hard to do so first of all the
kosher schwartz inequality is
clearly true if either a or b is zero
because then both the left and right
hand side will be zero right because
you'll have
the inner product of any vector with
zero zero that's the left-hand side and
on the right-hand side you'd have
one of the terms would be the norm of a
zero vector okay
so we can assume that both a
and b are non-zero and that means that
their norms and we'll call those
alpha and beta uh are positive so these
are positive numbers
now what we're going to do is we're
going to simply uh
do this we're going to say that zero is
less than or equal to and what we're
going to do is write out
uh it's a particular linear combination
of a and b
it's kind of weird actually it's just
basically
you know it's the norm of the norm of b
times a minus
the norm of a times b that's a linear
combination
and we're going to expand out this the
norm
squared of this difference and we get
something that looks like this it's the
norm squared of the first term
norm squared of the last term minus
twice the inner product
of the two terms and so that's going to
be this thing
here uh we're going to rearrange a
couple of things like here the beta
will come out and it comes out as beta
squared here alpha comes out as alpha
squared
i'm using properties of the norm there
and then here using some properties of
the inner product
the alpha and beta come out in front and
you get something like this
right so in this case we get
this this expression here and what we
get is that that's the same
as as this thing as we get we get 2
times the norm squared of a norm squared
b
minus 2 times norm a norm b here what
i've done
is i've used the fact that alpha is the
norm of a and
beta here is the norm of b and when you
plug those back in you get this thing
and what we know is that that thing is
bigger than or equal to zero
this first one applies immediately
because a norm is bigger than zero norm
squared is bigger than zero
so that's how you get that now if you
simply divide that
by this you get kosher schwartz
inequality and
you can also apply it to minus a and b
and you get the other half of the kosher
shorts inequality so that's the koshi
schwartz inequality
um i have to admit this is
this is what we call a mystery proof uh
like
because you look at it and you'd say
where on earth did why who would think
of taking writing down the norm square
to this bizarre
uh inner product uh this sorry linear
combination here
um and you know that's okay there's lots
of other ways to derive the coaching
schwarz inequality this is just one of
those so
i'm just saying i i would not have
expected you to do this but
i've done it for you so that's fine
okay now that we have the koshi schwartz
inequality uh we can actually talk about
angle
uh and the reason let me explain how
that goes it says
that the ratio if you have two non-zero
vectors then the ratio
of a transpose b to norm of a norm b
now we know by koshi schwartz that
that's a number between minus one and
plus one
can't can't be any outside that range
well that means that we can actually
take the arc
cosine and that means that we can
actually take um
we we can simply uh
we we can associate an angle with that
and we're going to literally define that
to be the angle between the two vectors
a and b
okay so that's that that's how that's
going to work um and it's going to be a
number between 0 and pi
or if you prefer uh degrees uh this is
radians
0 and 180 degrees and it's it's the one
that's going to satisfy this
that that the inner product is norm a
norm b times the cosine
of the angle between a and b um now this
is
turns out this is exactly the angle uh
in in two dimensions and three
that you knew about and maybe an
analytic analytic algebra analytic
geometry course
it is exactly the same as the angle
right if i say what's the what's the
angle between these two vectors you
would get exactly this formula
what's interesting for us is that the
formula
works and we associate angles between
vectors
of dimension 1000 right so which is
sort of interesting we'll get to that by
the way the angle is another kind of
measure
of deviation between uh two two vectors
right if the angle is two degrees
it means roughly speaking the vectors
are pointing kind of in the same
direction
if it's 90 degrees not so much and the
most they could they could disagree with
each other would be to point
in a 180 degrees apart from each other
but we'll we'll get to that in a minute
okay so um people classify angles
these are very useful to know about so
i'm going to take theta that's a
traditional symbol
to denote an angle is the angle between
two non-zero vectors a and b
so if theta is pi over 2
that means that a and b are orthogonal
and and people write it this way you
write a with this little upside down
thing
which suggests 90 degrees right um
a is orthogonal to b and it's just a
very fancy way of saying that the two
vectors are have an inner product of
zero
that that's it means nothing more um
if theta is zero that means that a and b
are aligned uh so
let me first give you an example
visually so here's an example of
orthogonal vectors right so the blue and
the red vectors
are orthogonal they have an angle of 90
degrees with respect to each other
aligned means that the inner product
is takes on the largest value could
possibly take given the norms and it's
norm a times norm b
and that occurs when basically roughly
speaking they point in the same
direction that's what i mean it means
the angle between them is zero
um if if theta
is 180 degrees uh or pi radians
right that means they're anti-aligned
and that would be this picture here
it says that they're actually on a line
but they point in exact opposite
direction so that's anti-aligned
if the angle is less than 90 degrees
then that says that the inner product is
is non-negative
and we call that we say that they make
an acute angle
and the conver not the converse but
if if it's bigger than 90 degrees we say
it's an obtuse angle so here's an
example
these two vectors make an acute angle i
don't know what the angle is between
them 25 degrees or something but
it's acute um oh and uh and the inner
product is is is non-negative in that
case positive
um in this case um the angle is more
than a 90 degrees i don't know 110 100
degrees i don't know some 105 degrees
anyway so this would be an example of
two vectors that make an obtuse angle so
and these are just completely standard
uh concepts in all of math so
this is what you're going to see okay
um another application is a spherical
distance
so here if i have a sphere
of radius r um and a and b are on the
sphere
so this is supposed to be a point on the
surface and that's a point on the
surface
then there i can talk about this
right so the distance between a and b
that's this thing
that is the distance but that that's
that's the distance of
you know basically let's if this was the
earth and these are two places
of drilling a hole directly from one
through the earth to the other
and that would give you this number here
okay
the distance along the sphere says you
have to what's the shortest dis
shortest path from one to the other but
you have to stay on the surface of the
sphere
okay so no drilling if you do that it
turns out that's exactly equal to the
radius times the angle the angle in
radians of course
not in degrees that gives you spherical
distance so that's another way to think
of
to think of an angle as giving
giving you some kind of a spherical
distance right so that's
that's kind of the idea um
the last thing we're going to talk about
in this section is that you can use
you can use a document dissem you can
measure things like document
dissimilarity
or feature distance using angles and
people do that
and so a lot of times people will say oh
how are you measuring
the feature distance and they might say
oh by angles right or by distance right
euclidean distance
but let's look at an example we're going
to look at the same one we looked at
uh last time a previous example
and what we do is we have five wikipedia
pages
one veterans day memorial day academy
awards golden globe award super bowl
and for each of those we're going to
work out a vector which is
the word count vector with a dictionary
of around 4 500 words
right so that that's we just do that
and then what we do is we're going to
calculate the angles
between pairs of these things now
whenever you ask what's the angle
between the vector and itself it's
always 0. so the diagonals are all
zero here let's see
let's um let's look at the angle between
veterans day
and so you could ask again which two of
which two of these feature vectors the
features the feature vectors are nothing
but word count vectors
which do have the smallest angle so
which ones are closest together
in an angle right and so once again
the winner is uh veterans day
and memorial day so by that it's
suggesting that somehow
of these five five wikipedia pages these
are the two
closest now they are literally the
closest as measured by angle
uh in feature space right but the
interesting thing is it actually
it picks up on some stuff and you would
probably if i asked you
if i went to a person on the street and
said here's five here's five wikipedia
pages
which which would you consider to be the
two that are closest you'd probably pick
these two but you might pick academy
awards and golden globe awards
um oh yes indeed you might because guess
what
that's actually the closest one my
apologies okay
but they're close and that gives you a
rough idea
interestingly you see things like this
golden globe awards and super bowl are
off by 86 degrees um now
the inner product of two word count
vectors word count vectors are
non-negative and the inner product of
two non-negative vectors non-negative
vector means a vector that's
all of whose entries are not negative
the inner product of
of of two such vectors is of course
non-negative and that means
that all of these angles had to be acute
they have to be between 0 and 90 degrees
so what's interesting about this this 86
degrees is it's saying that they're
pretty
they're pretty far apart they're about
as far apart as they could possibly be
90 being the only other choice or the
biggest that's the biggest they could
possibly be
by the way i should add that for word
count vectors if the angle is 90 degrees
it turns out there's only it means that
the two documents
share zero words in common in other
words that for every single word in that
dictionary
either it's either it's not in one
document or it's not in the other
you could look at that or we'll make a
homework problem on it to have you work
that out and figure out what it means
anyway so once again this is a hint that
looking at just
angles um can actually have practical
applications
next topic is the so-called correlation
coefficient
again this is something you'll see in
other courses i'm pretty sure or may
already have seen in a basic
probability course here we're here we're
defining it in the context of well
vectors right so what we do is we take
two vectors a and b
we d mean them so i get a tilde and b
tilde
i should add that this is not uh this is
not universal mathematics notation
so it's it's my local notation so don't
go to the math department
and say a tilde and they can they go
what are you talking about
and you can't say it's the d mean vector
they would say well i didn't know that
so
um just so you know i mean you you can
write
this the inner product and that everyone
will recognize
but not the tildes so just just so you
know okay
so we demean these vectors um and the
correlation coefficient is defined it's
it's used uh this is the
that that is kind of a standard
mathematical uh symbol for correlation
rho the greek uh greek character letter
rho
and it's equal to the inner product of
the d meaned
vectors divided by the product of the
norms now if you took
the arc cosine of this you would get the
angle between the d mean vectors
okay so here what this means is
you know if rho is so rho is literally
the cosine
of the of the angle between them so rho
equals zero
means that they're uncorrelated and it
means a tilde and b
tilde are um orthogonal
right that that they have zero inner
product
um if rho is bigger than about 0.8 or so
it depends on the application
you would say that a and b are highly
correlated if it's less than minus 0.8
you'd say they're they're highly
anti-correlated
now you might ask what does this
correlation coefficient mean
and what it means is actually super
interesting it means the following
you take these ais and bis and you ask
questions like
when are they above their average like
for what eyes are they above their
average and
when are they below their average and if
that has nothing to do with each other
and sometimes you know
a is above its average and b is below
and sometimes you know that kind of
thing
then they're going to be approximately
uncorrelated if however
they're correlated what that tells you
they're highly correlated
what that says is very often when a is
above its average so is b
that they they co uh well they're they
it's more or less kind of at the same
time roughly
that they uh they're above their their
averages so that that's roughly the
the idea here um so
here's an example uh we've got
three examples of pairs of vectors which
we've plotted just
so your eye so just for your eye to
follow it
here's a here's b and in this first one
you take a look at it you know i don't
know what the mean is but i'd say it's
about there
and i don't know what the mean of this
is but you know it's not too different
like that
um and now again let's use my uh
my intuitive idea of what correlation is
you could see that you know it's over
here in index like two three four
whatever roughly that a is above its
mean
and sure enough b is above its mean
maybe not in the first one but in two
three four five something like that
and also similarly a is below its mean
here
and so is b and sure enough that these
are
very highly correlated and if i do a
scatter plot of a
against b what it says is they kind of
fall on a line that's what it means to
have perfect correlation so they have
they fall on a line like this
okay um our second example
is here's a here's b and again i don't
know what the mean might be somewhere
around here
and here they're anti-correlated because
you see when a goes high
b goes low high means high means above
its mean
and b goes low and as a result when i
scatter plot a versus b
they're on this declining line like this
and
that means uh they're anti-correlated
and here
sure enough the they're highly
anti-correlated
and here's an example where when you do
a scatter plot of a and b
they're just kind of all over the map
and you can see here a is above its mean
sometimes so is b
but all four things happen you know i
mean i'm being very rough here
but approximately the same right with
same frequencies you know
sometimes they have a is above b is
below sometimes a is above b's above and
all four possibilities you get um so
that's it oh i should add that uh things
like uh
correlation uh is is also defined in
basic probability
um and in fact this corresponds
precisely to that
uh in in a certain setting but but here
it's just i'm just talking about for
vectors
so okay
so here are some examples practical
examples of highly correlated vectors
um here we go how about the rain the
daily
rainfall time series in palo alto and
menlo park
there you go these are adjacent cities
okay
so i mean honestly they're often very
they're very close so these would be
highly correlated right that
in the summer in california you
basically don't have any rain at all
you know when it's raining in palo alto
it's probably raining in menlo park this
kind of thing so
so that would be an example of highly
correlated
um highly correlated vectors would be
like 10 years of daily rainfall data
that would be a
3650 vector
long okay here's another one maybe not
as highly correlated
is daily returns of of similar companies
in the same industry
so let's look at let's say a year's
worth of returns
uh there's about 250 trading days in a
year so that's about 250 numbers
so if i look at you know two similar
companies
and i look at their returns they will be
if if the companies are similar meaning
they've got about the same
capitalization
they kind of are in the same industry or
something like that
of course the returns are not going to
be the same but they're going to be
pretty correlated because
some of the same things are driving both
of them right some of the same
underlying causes
and so that's the idea correlation is
not going to be
95 but it could easily be 0.8 or
something like that
um here's another one uh word count
vectors of closely related documents are
going to be
highly correlated um so that's uh
that that that that's that that's an
example right so
for example uh uh things written by the
same
author or things on the same topic right
so
uh there's these are gonna be fairly
correlated right um
so um okay uh here's another one
it's a classic one from economics it's
kind of silly but
it's the sale maybe a time series of
sales
uh let's say weekly sales of shoes and
socks
um you know and those are going to be
uh those could be at different locations
or different periods
and then the point is those are
correlated because basically when people
are buying shoes
they're probably also buying socks i
mean so it
you know are they exactly the same of
course not but you know you would see
that they were
they were highly correlated um so
examples have some
approximately uncorrelated vectors um
it's just
two vectors that are unrelated right so
um
an example would be uh go get the the
the daily maximum temperature in
bordeaux for 10 years and i have a 3650
vector
okay there it is it's just it's just it
varies right
it's cool and the cool in the winter and
not you know high in the summer i don't
know
okay and i go and i get uh let's say
the rainfall in the amazon forest
actually i should be careful because
those probably would have some
correlation
seasonality but i i could actually just
go get some other
vector of the same length and then
oh yeah it could be simply this it could
be the
weekly purchases at a company of 3650
different products
right so the point is they have nothing
to do with each other and
quite likely they are going to be uh
essentially uncorrelated
um a practical example is is audio
signals
right so um when i take if i
you know audio signals are encoded as
vectors of length which is about 44 000
per second so even a 10 second clip is
pretty big it's 440
441 000 actually uh long
and if i just take two audio clips that
are each about a you know each uh
10 seconds long they're going to be
approximately uncorrelated
i mean almost very very closely i mean
unless
they were two microphones recorded you
know with you know within you know half
an inch of each other or something in
which case the correlation coefficient
might creep up
but other than that they're going to be
completely uncorrelated i mean
approximately
okay um so if you want to look for some
negatively correlated vectors
daily temperatures in palo alto and
melbourne okay
why because once the northern hemisphere
when the southern hemisphere
and you know kind of when it's above
the mean yearly temperature in palo alto
it's because of summer and that's
exactly winter in melbourne
so that's that's kind of that would be
an example of that so these are just
you know some examples to give you the
flavor of what of what it means to be
correlated
you